Justin your wife Haley has some very
famous friends that she is really close
to it rain ranked these friends of hers
from your favorite to your least
favorite GG spoiler alert Gigi Hadid
Kendall Jenner and Cara Delevingne from
your favorite to your least favorite
Kendall
Gigi Cara Delevingne yep the Biebs was
totally in the hot seat on Thursday
night's Late Late Show with James Corden
where he played our favorite game spill
your guts or feel your guts
not only did he rank Hayley's famous
friends but he also explained why he
ranked them in that order and real talk
his reasons make a lot of sense
[Applause]
let's go back to it though I know
Kendall the bet I've spent the most time
with Kendall you know yes a good friend
of ours mm-hmm I haven't spent a lot of
time with Gigi yep and I haven't spent a
lot of time with car so I have nothing
against those people it's just I'm have
a better relationship all right
so I was like oh no screwed car listen
you were faced with eeeh bull's penis
right seriously
respect there's just no way Haley could
get mad at that I love it one thing
Justin would not spill his guts on his
believers Justin you have performed all
over the world which country has the
worst fans
[Applause]
got his heart now the rest of the show
oh okay okay but don't worry Justin got
his turn with James asking him about a
little movie called cats on a scale of
one to ten how much to regret doing cats
so one is the least and tell is the most
well here's the thing I had the
loveliest time making that film okay
it took me six days great and I loved
every single second of it
yeah so I'm gonna put it at a solid five
[Applause]
that's also fair but James would not
cave when Justin asked him dude I'm
ready five years old your friend Harry
Styles is also 25 years old which 25
year old is more talented chance bright
hilarious
Justin of course appeared with Corden as
part of the promo tour for his new album
changes the album was largely inspired
by the Biebs his wife Haley you know
this is an album I wrote in the first
year of our marriage you know so it's
like it's so fresh and there's you know
there's no there's so much more to learn
about commitment and you know building
trust and foundation I'm just I'm
looking forward to continuing to build
and make music that's gonna reflect that
all right guys that's it for today for
all the latest on Justin
Haley and your other favorite celebs
stick with all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krause and bye for now